the u.s has pledged to take sudan off
its list of terrorism state sponsors
in exchange it wants khartoum to pay out
hundreds of millions to terror victims
in true modern diplomacy style the
american president and his sudanese
counterpart
took to twitter to discuss the deal
great news new government of sudan which
is making great progress
agreed to pay 335 million dollars to u.s
terror victims and families
once deposited i will lift sudan from
the state sponsors of terrorism list
thank you so much president trump we
very much look forward to your official
notification to congress
rescinding the designation of sudan as a
state sponsor of terrorism
which has cost sudan too much currently
washington's list of terrorist states
includes four countries so there's sudan
but then also iran
north korea and syria this means they're
subject to sanctions they can't get
foreign aid from the u.s
there's also a ban on arms sales and a
number of financial restrictions
sudan was initially designated a terror
state after harboring al-qaeda leader
osama bin laden
[Music]
[Applause]
ramsay baru told us he's editor of the
palestine chronicle he said that he
believes
the upcoming u.s election played a big
role in this latest move
of course this is a devastating
political statement
that the issue then turned out not to be
really about terrorism
if that was ever the subject of the u.s
sudan conflict but it is about money i
mean
imagine what kind of a president this is
going to send
not just within that region but
worldwide
but i really think it was never about
money in the first place
uh trump is desperate to go back to his
supporters and to claim
another uh foreign policy victory
especially uh because in few days there
would be another
uh debate that will focus largely on
foreign policy
so he needs to go and and talk about his
achievements and sudan in addition to uh
the emirates and bahrain would be the
latest
of his achievements as far as he is
concerned this is really more about u.s
elections
than about money percent